a very warm greeting to one and all my
name is Shari and I would like to
welcome you all for the orientation
session for omix logic biomed fall
training programs and this fall we are
excited to conduct programs on
intruction to multiomics genomics
metagenomics transcriptomics and
biomedical data science using python so
before we begin with today's orientation
session let me also take a brief moment
to introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible and we have had the
opportunity to work with coordinators
from different parts of the world to
provide bioinformatic training programs
in different specializations including
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine neuroscience and bi medical
data science now the key features of the
program include an industry relevant
modern asynchronous curriculum with both
code and noncode modules you'll be
guided by an expert bioinformatics team
and gain hands-on experience with
essential bioinformatic tools algorithms
and data repositories and at the end of
the program you'll have the opportunity
to work on a research proposal and
receive expert feedback and this has
been a achieved through a combination of
online lectures bioinformatic data
analysis tools curated data sets
practical assignments Hands-On coding
exercises and interactive Mentor
sessions now to further enrich the
training curriculum we also provide real
case studies that demonstrate the
Practical applications of bioinformatic
methods and omix data in fields such as
medicine biotechnology Agriculture and
even astrobiology
now as I mentioned during the training
program you will be given options for
analyzing a given data set these include
code dependent Pathways or code
independent Pathways now if you're
someone interested in opting the
non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the T binfo
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run different btic
pipelines on genomics tromics
metagenomics and so on and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multiomic
platform we will be covering about this
in a short while and at the end of the
training program you'll acquire a
comprehensive skill set including a deep
understanding of biological Concepts as
well as the processes governing their
interactions you will also develop
strong computational skills and
proficiency and programming languages
such as Python and R you will also gain
expertise in statistical methods to
analyze large omix data set so now to
view the various courses example
projects you need to first start by
signing up on the omix logic lawn portal
where you'll be getting access to the
training resources as well so here is
the link for signing up and this is for
those uh participants who have not
signed up on the portal yet if so please
follow along I'll just walk you through
the steps on um how you can get started
so in my email uh I've mentioned the
steps for signing up and here's how you
can do the same for those of you who
have not signed up click on the create
an account option that you see here and
you'll be asked to enter few details
such as your name email ID password uh
your University and so on make sure that
you log in using your University uh
credentials and if you already have an
existing account on the portal you can
directly click and login now and enter
your existing email ID and password and
sign in so with that I'll just pause for
a couple of seconds if the participants
have any queries about signing up or if
you're facing any technical issues we'll
address them and then uh proceed forward
so I'll
um monitoring the chat box please put a
yes in the chat box if you have already
created an account on the
portal so that I get an
idea okay thank you so much uh I have
received one response what about the
rest of you have you also signed up or
if you want me to walk you through once
again about how to sign up please let me
know and I'll be happy to do
that thank you so much Dr
Maria we'll email out the steps once
again so that if participants are facing
any issues on how to sign up um you can
just follow along the steps so for now
I'm just proceeding with signing up and
how you can uh get
started all right so once you sign up uh
the very first thing that you have to do
is to set up your account on the omix
logic loarn portal to do that head over
to the blue bar on the top that says
welcome back with your email ID click on
that and it will directly take you to
your profile settings now you need to
have a completed profile um to start
with the program and to do that you can
click on this profile button that you
see here and you'll be asked to enter a
few details make sure that your name is
in proper capitalization and with proper
spelling because these uh this name will
be printed on your certificates once you
complete the training program and add a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and some of your research interest as
well and uh you can also add a link to
your social media Handles in my case
I've um added my LinkedIn profile and ID
and also add a profile image it could be
your own image or it could be the logo
of your University as well so once all
of the these features are updated it
should be showing 100% profile
completion now during your training
program we will be monitoring your
learning activity in this act activity
log as displayed here and we'll be
reaching out to you in case um we notice
that you're being inactive or stuck
somewhere and now under the courses tab
it will display the various cours workk
progress that you're making uh in the
training program and this is one of the
important parts that you have to keep in
mind when you head over to your profile
and you click on the program uh tab in
the white bar that you see here it will
display the program that you are
currently involved in so once you click
on this it will directly take you to the
program page where you'll be able to get
started with um watching the lecture
videos and accessing the various online
courses and now under the certificates
stab whenever you complete a particular
course work you will receive a separate
um certificate for that as well as once
you complete each of the levels of the
training program you will be receiving
the uh relevant certificates for that as
well so that is all that I wanted to um
walk you through about with uh getting
started and now to uh get started with
each of these training programs what are
the various resources what are the
curriculum I'd like to pass on the stage
to my colleague SAR Kar to uh get
started over to you s thank you so much
Shari and uh hello everyone a very warm
good morning to you all before we get
started before I take you through the
program uh what is the program like what
are the different types of programs that
we are offering this fall and also what
each and every program consists of it
would be great if we could first of all
hear from each one of you what is your
background and uh you're from which lab
and what is your research work or if you
you're a student then you're from which
uh core or or what degree you are
pursuing right now so let's start with
Camilo uh you can switch on your camera
if you can and uh please unmute yourself
please introduce yourself we would like
to know uh what is your background if
you're a researcher you are associated
with which lab if you're a student you
are associated with which university
what is your degree and uh what
motivates you to join the program Ciro
can we hear from
you
hello how you
doing hi my name ISO I'm a biochemistry
Jr at LSU and over the summer I did an
internship at cancer research center and
I saw some bioinformatics work and I was
really interested in learning about it
I'm more or so on the experimental and
like bench top research but I wanted to
know more about the software and the
technology side of
things all right so have you registered
for the program already or you have
joined to learn about the programs and
then take up
one I signed up for the genomics
program okay right all right next is
nimrat nimrat said she can speak uh you
are a PI from University of wmount all
right what is your field nimra it would
be great if you can tell me interested
more about bioinformatics side of things
apart from your expertise s biology all
right got it and which program have you
taken up have you already enrolled or
you wish to enroll now you can put in
the
chat okay we'll discuss about the
programs what we'll cover in each one of
them and then you can take a call thank
you next is Da can we hear from you yes
uh yes my name is daa um PD student in
University of New
Orleans um my major is computer science
but but I'm working in bi informatic
research um my disertation is about um
infair Gene regularity network using uh
bulk data sets um uh bulk RNA sequence
and single cell RNA sequence data I have
like issue with dealing single cell RNA
sequence data and um I need to
understand more about this type of data
uh and like
I use it in my
research all right single cell is one of
those areas that I'm very fond of to uh
work on the analysis good to have you
with us I'll take you through the bul
and the single set RN SE program and uh
it would be the best for you to take it
up thank
you uh we have Dr Maria with us hi Dr
Maria I know you but others don't know
you so can you please introduce
yourself sure hi sonal so I am Maria
Sanchez from NIS orans I'm being with
those guys already like I don't know one
year and a half maybe so I'm being
learning biop formatics and I am working
in cancer research and
Immunology um doing several things like
a r SI and attack sick chip six so I'm
being learning a
lot thank you thank you Dr Maria and uh
we have a an with us can you please
introduce
yourself hello everyone yeah how you
doing so my name is Anthony aoso I'm
with
LSU uh School of veterinary medicine I'm
in the comparative biomedical
Sciences uh and I'm having my
PhD in biomedical science so
um my background um is in Biochemistry
from the University of Lagos in Nigeria
and right now I am working with Dr
Charles Lee in uh new systems that's the
FI under neuro uh Neuroscience so I'm a
first year PhD and uh very soon maybe in
my second year I will have to develop
proposals so um I'm looking for how I
can incorporate uh knowledge in bi
informatics into Neuroscience research
so that's why I
have uh have uh applied interest to do
uh introduction to Big Data by
informatics all right we have worked on
several neuro degenerated disorders uh
we have worked on Alzheimer's
Parkinson's and red syndrome as well so
we have these case studies I'll just
take you shortly on the portal and I'll
showcase you these case studies it would
be very interesting for you to have a
look at these different case studies
using different types of data R data
also metagenomics data for red syndrome
so okay thank you right thank you very
much you're welcome we have have uh
rames with us he's not able to speak no
problem uh so you are a post doctoral
researcher and you have worked on Patric
surgery myoid cell biology and cancer uh
chronic inflammation that's interesting
I've never heard about bariatric surgery
before I'll definitely look into it what
it is uh thank you so much uh Dr Ramesh
for introducing yourself and Dr R have
you taken the programs before as well
because uh we had uh Dr a lot of Dr
rames with us I'm not sure if you joined
before are you new to omix logic or have
you taken up a program with us
before share my screen in the me
time all right
so
I'll okay Dr rames is new welcome okay
so I will take you all through the
different fall programs that we are
offering I'll just discuss very briefly
what all these programs are about and uh
what will we cover in the programs and
what would be the resources for the
programs so that you can take up a
decision which specific program you
would like to join all right so uh I'll
just uh take you through all of it now
and uh so this this fall we are
offering uh five specific programs so on
the omic learn portal you'll see that
there are several programs around omic
data analysis which covers RNA seek
analysis single cell genomics
metagenomics and also specialization
tracks like infectious diseases uh but
this fall we are specifically offering
five programs which includes multiomic
bio informatics to introduce non
bioinformaticians to the field of
bioinformatics because it's um
everywhere in all the fields right now
and it's very important for even all the
biologists or medical students to really
know about the field
bioinformatics and then we'll uh are
also offering metag genomic data
analysis genomic data analysis
transcriptomic data analysis training
programs to understand how these
different types of Armic data could be
analyzed and and uh a very important
tool that is used to analyze different
types of data is python so the last
program that is up is the biomedical
data science in Python program so I now
take you through each one of these
programs one by one and these are some
of the specifications about each one of
these
programs so so the first program is uh
uh introduction to
bioinformatics now introduction to
bioinformatics program has been designed
for uh newbies or the ones who are from
a non- bioinformatics field or
biotechnology field and you might have
heard a lot about what bioinformatics is
all about and you might be curious of
how do we really use it so what is
bioinformatics bioinformatics is the
science of both storing lots of complex
biological data and also of analyzing it
to find new insights which we use in
many different ways and today's
biomedical
researchers uh the research on
biomedical data isn't simply about
publishing one set of results and hoping
that other researchers read it it's
about finding patterns in all the forms
of data linking everything that is out
there to provide new insights that we
can only spot if we see the bigger
picture bi informatics lets us bring
together the data from lots of
experiments in one uh place so we can
ask those big questions and find the
answers and such data from different
sources is available and rather than the
availability of such Rich sources of
data the changes it changes the nature
of biological research itself as it's
rapidly acquiring the character of a
data science
now who uses bioinformatics and who is
it for the answer might have been
statisticians computer scientists or
Engineers but the truth is that more and
more biologists and clinicians are now
expected to understand and handle their
own data to publish and succeed in basic
and translational research in fact
biology itself is rapidly acquiring the
character of a data
science so as biology is rapidly
acquiring the character of a data
science that that that I just mentioned
there are billions of data points on
genes proteins as well as other
molecules that are compiled in large
files and they're systematically studied
and analyzing this data leads to more
knowledge and understanding about living
organisms which includes human health
biotechnology crops and lifestock so in
the training program we will give you an
overview of bioinformatics for
understanding multiomic data analysis
now when I say multiomic data analysis
we'll give you an introduction to
different types of omic data be it
genomics data transcriptomics data
single cell data or metag genomics data
or even epigenomics data so we'll
introduce you to these different types
of data resources from where you can
extract these different types of data
what you can analyze with the data and
how do you do that but the program is
not uh in depth analysis of each one of
these different omix uh data types but
we'll just give you an introduction we
did not want to make an introductory
program much heavy and that is why we
have specialized courses that you can
pick to understand how specific analysis
related questions could be answered be
it from the field of genomics
transcriptomics or metagenomics
so I just wanted to mention here that we
have these different types of omix data
that we have introduced in the program
and we would also discuss about the
different types of tools and techniques
that we could use to analyze this data
to analyze multiomic data now there are
several data repositories that we could
leverage from I understand there are uh
several pis while generating data in
their lab
and they have the access to to the data
for analysis and have their research
work done but there are students who
want to learn how to extract data from
publicly uh from public repositories and
also learn how to perform different
types of analysis to answer a specific
research question so there are different
types of repositories from where you can
extract the data you can pre-process the
data or clean the data and then analyze
it to uh extract meaningful insights out
of it so in the program we introduce you
to different repositories or databases I
should say from where you you can
extract different types of omix data so
the program is designed to highlight the
role of big omix data that is shaping
the modern biomedical Innovation where
molecular data is used for precision
Diagnostics Big Data integration as well
as machine learning that is now
transforming personalization of
treatment selection and Innovative
algorithms that allow for unprecedented
capabilities with drug Discovery design
of large molecules and even drug
repurposing so we'll cover some of the
important technologies that have
mentioned uh with its applications in
today's worlds and the participants will
be able to access bio informatics
resources along with expert and Mentor
support to get help with the learning
process that will help you learn the
transformation of biology to datadriven
biology now let's discuss about the next
program that is genomic data analysis so
whether you are just starting your
journey or looking to expand your
expertise this program is designed to
provide you with the skills and the
knowledge that is needed to excel in
this rapidly evolving field so there are
three different levels that we have
designed for all these programs the
first is the beginner level then we have
the intermediate mediate level and then
we have the advanced level in the
beginner level of genomic data analysis
program you will develop a strong
Foundation exploring bioinformatics NGS
and uh gain an ability to explore and
even analyze genomic data through data
exploration and also through uh sequence
alignment and there are many more
different types of analysis that we
would be doing so from advancements in
NGS
to understanding the entire workflow
from sequencing reads quality control
alignment and annotation which files are
involved what it includes how to prepare
them and what are the steps of analysis
what parameters to use and finally how
to annotate the variants that are
observed when the reads are aligned on
the reference genome is what we'll cover
in the program in the beginner level of
the program and we'll further discuss
more in the intermediate level that will
take you deeper into the Intriguing
topics such as variant calling we have a
dedicated Pipeline on the tbio info
server for variant calling I just take
you through that as well we'll also
discuss about copy number variation
analysis uh machine learning genomewide
Association studies and ethical
considerations as well and for those who
are seeking Advanced knowledge we will
delve into population genetics DN
sequencing analysis VCF file analysis
functional annotation and also we'll
discuss all of these different concepts
with real life case studies on SAR scov
2 breast cancer enogen variant calling
and even
Ebola so by joining this program you
will gain a practical hands-on
experience you will learn Cutting Edge
techniques and you'll unravel the
Mysteries that are hidden within the
genomic data so be prepared to unlock a
world of exciting POS possibilities and
make significant contributions in the
field these are some of the uh research
projects that we have worked upon uh so
once you complete the training program
you can have a research proposal ready
and for the work on Independent research
project if you're a student it would be
helpful to you to submit it in your
college as a desertation or have a
publication for higher studies so that
was about the genomic data analysis
program and for students they often look
for the potential career Pathways after
uh being trained with a specific type of
analysis the question is what specific
career pathway can we choose now where
can we apply the knowledge that we have
gained so once the programs uh are
towards completion we'll also have a
session a discussion on different career
Pathways and we keep on posting
different jobs as well job openings on
theologic learn portal that I'll take
you through that would be helpful for
you you to pick your dream job now let's
discuss about the next program that is
metagenomic data analysis to unravel the
microbial Community now to explore the
Limitless potential of metagenomic data
and Analysis through our comprehensive
training program we have again designed
these different levels beginner
intermediate and advanced so whether you
are starting your journey or seeking to
expand your expertise this program
equips you with with the skills and the
knowledge toell in the dynamic
field so let's quickly discuss what is
metagenomics all about and where did it
come from so in the 1800s the link
between the disease and the
microorganisms was established sharing
light on isolated bacteria functions and
today we understand that the human
microbiome consists of structured
communities forming biofilms with
complex interactions aiding ecological
stability an advances in metagenomics
enables the study of the vast majority
of uncultivable microorganisms within
their natural
environments so this course would cover
bioinformatics analysis of metagenomic
sequencing data which includes genomic
sequencing Technologies data data uh
utilization analysis tools and also the
real world
applications now since
1990s the microbiome studies have made
significant progress notably through
initiatives like the human microbiome
project that has enabled metagenomic
sequencing advances allowing
characterization of microbiota in
various human organs and it presents
opportunities and challenges in
identifying their roles in organ health
and diseases in this program we
will learn about the different types of
metagenome sequencing techniques to
different types of data that is
generated such as OD sequences that is
annotated by mapping on to a reference
database such as RDP that is ribosomal
database project green genes or the
silver database and such databases
contain exomic information for the
domains of bacteria ARA and ukaria based
primarily on phenes for small subunit
rrnas that is 16s for procaryotes and
18s for ukar
now I'll uh skip some of the basics on
metagenomic analysis we'll discuss more
about it in the uh
program and uh I wanted to mention here
that in the metagenomics program we'll
cover two major pipelines one is the
data 2 pipeline where we understand uh
this one is the tonomy classification
Pipeline and then we'll go to the data
the data two pipeline that will help you
Den noise and correct the errors in
amplicon sequence data and provide you
with high resolution error free sequence
variance we'll learn what the flow of
the pipeline is what the workflow or the
steps involved are what parameters to
use for different types of sequencing
that is done and how to interpret the
results dat to pipeline will give you
abundance tables pH phog gentic trees
and will also help you with the alpha
diversity and the beta diversity as an
output and we'll also go through the
kind to pipeline which will help you
analyze and process microbial Community
data offering diverse outputs again like
taxonomic assignments diversity Matrix
and various
visualizations also in the metagenomics
data analysis program we will learn
about uh using R for different types of
analysis so the PIP thingses that I
showed you
behind them are popular coding languages
such as R and Python and we also have in
the coursework tutorials explained in R
to help you understand how you can use a
computational script to analyze
metagenomic
data it would include bner tutorials on
data importing preparation for analysis
and also standard visualization of
processed data and there are more
specialized packages with publication
ready outputs that will also be covered
in more advanced
lessons so that was all about the
metagenomic data analysis program and if
we talk about some of the applications
of practical examples of metagenomic
sequencing so you will learn about the
applications of metagenomic uh data
analysis that would include uh studying
about skin conditions food sensitivity
of the gut autoimmune disorders cancer
antibiotic resistance drug resistance
and and even ecological studies we have
several case studies that we have put
together uh on the omic logic learn
portal uh that that that I'll take you
through to understand how the different
concepts of omix analysis could be
applied to several research questions in
the real
world last but not the least I want to
discuss about the Python program uh why
Python program why biomedical data
science using Python program so we have
put together this program as the demand
for skilled data analysts and scientists
who can derive meaningful insights from
biomedical data has increased it's never
been greater and that's where our online
Mentor guided training program on
biomedical data science using python
comes into
play in today's rapidly evolving world
of biomedical research the generation of
big data has become the norm and every
day there are vast amounts of valuable
biomedical data that is being produced
used holding the potential to
revolutionize our understanding of
diseases and also pave the way for
groundbreaking medical discoveries
however the sheer volume and the
complexity of this data presents a
significant Challenge and that's where
data analysis comes in so this
comprehensive program is designed to
equip you with the knowledge and the
skills that you need to excel in the
field of biomedical data science through
a combination of practical assignments
live workshops and online resources that
you'll embark on as you'll embark on a
transformative Learning Journey that
will Empower you to unlock the potential
of high throughput biomedical data now
in this program of biomedical data
science using python we'll also
introduce you to to different types of
omx data let's say you are a biologist
not not from the field of bioinformatics
and you have little idea about these
different types of f but not dealt with
the different types of omx data but when
when you have to Learn Python to deal
with biomedical data it's really
important for you to understand what
these different omix data would really
look like how you have to deal with them
so we introduce you in the beginner
level with all these different types of
omix data first of all we'll also
discuss how to extract this data how to
clean this data and how to analyze this
data
all with
python so we'll start by understanding
the basics such as data types variables
control structures functions and modules
as well and then we will dive into data
processing and cleaning where we will
use powerful libraries like numai and
pandas and then we will learn about
exploratory data analysis leveraging
visualization libraries like mat blot
lib and cabon to cover patterns and the
relationships that are H that are hidden
within your data Additionally you will
gain an understanding of dimensionality
reduction techniques and machine
learning using pyit learn uh Library so
as you progress to the intermediate
level you will deepen your understanding
of clustering and advanced machine
learning techniques that is specifically
tailored for biomedical data analysis
you will explore clustering techniques
like K means Edge clusterings spectral
clustering using python clustering
packages like Sait and scipi and then
you'll learn model validation techniques
and evaluation matrics for supervised
machine learning
models you'll also delve into advanced
machine learning techniques like
decision tree random Forest svm LDA and
umap and apply them to real world
biomedical data sets what are these
different algorithms how do they work
how do they create the machine learning
models and which one should be used for
what specific type of research question
that is what we would be discussing in
the program as well and last but not the
least I want to discuss this uh because
in today's datadriven world AI that has
powered uh a lot of Technologies like
chat GPD it is revolutionizing the way
we approach scientific research and data
analysis and as Learners you have a
remarkable opportunity to enhance or to
hardness the power of AI to unlock new
insights AI particularly the code
interpreter uh in chat GPD and now there
are different AI tools as well can
provide assistance by generating code
for complex analysis and automating
routine tasks additionally it can
produce insight for visualizations such
as heat Maps or dendograms and other
plots that that would help you visualize
and interpret your data effectively we
know that we can uh generate code we can
understand a code we can produce a code
and we can also create different types
of visualizations now with the uh chart
gpts uh paid version that they have that
they mention as GPT 4 but when it comes
to creating these visualizations it's
very important for you to understand the
logic of the analysis what logic to
apply uh for a specific type of
visualization what prompt you have to
use that you could input uh in these AI
tools to get the uh desired result that
you can use in your research
Publications so in the training programs
we'll be going through all of these
different techniques we'll discuss about
the logic for different aric analysis
that you have to use uh through which
you can uh generate these interesting
visualizations and plot
thoughts so that was all that I wanted
to discuss about the different training
programs and now I'll take you through
the omx logic learn portal where I'll
showcase you different resources that
you have an access to that you'll have
an access to as a part of the program so
um Shar can you just confirm if the omx
logic screen is visible and not my
slides yes you can see
the thank you all right so as sh
explained you about the omic learn
portal I hope you all have signed up now
if you have not cre created an account
yet please uh feel free to create one
I'll put the link in the chat now on the
omix logic learn portal once you have
signed up that there are two tabs that
are very important for you the first one
is the programs Tab and the another one
is the courses tab now on the under the
programs tab you'll see a lot of uh omix
analysis and research specialization
specific training programs that you can
enroll and uh learn from I'll today
discuss about these five programs that I
took you through the first one is
Introduction to Big Data
bioinformatics another one is
transcriptomics for biomedical research
then we have genomic data analysis
biomedical data science using python we
are also offering chem informatics if
anyone is you can let us know and uh
then you have on the second page you
have
metagenomics you can uh log to the
portal go to the programs Tab and feel
free to go over the curriculum and uh
once you have joined a specific
program uh so once you register for a
program we enroll you on the program
page and you'll find a badge of the same
program on your profile so you can also
access the program that you have
enrolled for through the program link
but you can also access it through the
badge here so if you have enrolled in
transcriptomics you'll have a badger if
you click on it you'll get redirected to
the program page now let us understand
what the program is uh program page is
for and what resources can you can you
leverage so once you are on the program
page you can see three different levels
that I mentioned the first one is
beginner then you have the intermediate
level and then you have the advanced
level the beginner level has six
sessions intermediate level also has six
sessions and advanced one has 12
sessions as a part of the program you
have the access to the intermediate
level but if you wish to extend it to
the advanced level you can reach out to
us and we'll help you with the extension
now let us see what are the components
of each session so if you click on the
drop- down button you'll get the the
sessions now for each session you have
different sections under which you have
a session video it's an embedded YouTube
unlisted video that you have to go
through and then you have an Associated
lesson I just go through this what it is
and then you have the additional reading
material it could be a reference paper a
reference book or even an interesting
video that could help you understand the
concept animate uh through animations so
that is what you'll get in the addition
reading material and in some of the
sessions you will also get the link to
the demo pipeline so if in a session the
mentor is explaining how to uh perform
or how to process or execute a pipeline
on the tbio info server you'll get the
link to the demo pipeline as well and
the link to the Practical uh lecture
would already be there under the section
of uh the topics where you will learn
how to process the pipeline the basis
the workflow the parameters to use and
what results you get how to interpret
them and for uh if you're interested to
run the pipeline or execute the pipeline
yourself and check how to do so you'll
get the link of the data as well that
you have under each uh session that you
can refer to you can see what the data
structure looks like and also run the
pipelines but uh we recommend that you
go through the demo pipelines where the
data is already uploaded I'll just show
you one and you can execute that
pipeline because it's quick and the
motive here is to understand the flow of
the pipeline and also to look at the
results and understand how to interpret
them so demo pipelines are easy to learn
quick to learn and once you have your
own data you can then process the
pipeline uh with your own data and
interpret your result
now let's go back to the component of
associated lessons some of you who are
joining uh us for the second or third
time would know how to access the
program page but I'll go through this
for the newbies here who have joined us
for the first time now what is an
Associated lesson an Associated lesson
you can click on it it will redirect you
to a lesson of the coursework so for all
these sessions that we have put together
here you have a coursework or a lesson
that you have to go through now from
where uh these courseworks come from
this is the courses tab I'll just take
you to that lesson link that I opened
but meanwhile I'll tell you from where
did we get the courses this this is the
courses tab now if you are a part of the
introduction to bioinformatics training
program you will have the access to some
introductory courses now what access of
which courses do you have have on the
training program page itself I think my
Internet is slow apologies for the same
on the training program page itself if
you scroll
down you'll see a program course and
project
Library so as a part of the program
you'll have the access to all of these
courses that you can go through you can
click on them they are they'll redirect
you to the course you can also search
for the course here so if this is the
course course has several lessons inside
it and you need to complete each one of
these lessons so if it's introduction to
bioinformatics in this course we are
introducing you to different types of
omix analysis be genomics
transcriptomics or metagenomics and also
the basis of
bioinformatics inside each lesson you'll
find the uh Concepts through Theory you
also have videos to watch and you also
have quizzes and and assignments to
answer so that is what constitutes a
lesson now this lesson would be linked
to each one of the sessions on the
program page so if you're going through
the first session you have to complete
the first lesson of introduction to
bioinformatics coursework as a part of
the session now not to complicate things
for you that's why we have put
everything on one program page you open
the session you watch the lectures you
go through the associated lesson you
read the additional material that we
have shared and proceed ahead now once
you complete the session you need to
click on the complete session Button as
well so that it's marked on your profile
that you have completed this session and
when you complete uh the 12 sessions of
the program only then the certificate
would be issued to you on your profile
you'll get it automatically on your
profile file from where you can download
so that was about the uh lectures that
you need to go through and the
associated lessons and the reading
material now for introduction to
bioinformatics I mentioned you have the
big intermediate advanc level and this
was the lesson link that I clicked on
just to show you how it redirects now
for transcriptomics I did not uh discuss
about the transcri prics program in my
slides so I'll give you a brief overview
about this program through the program
page itself uh in the beginner level
we'll discuss about different NGS uh
we'll different we'll discuss about
different techniques of NGS we'll
discuss about uh the different types of
sources for data extraction different
repositories and this is specific to RNC
data only in the beginner level and then
we'll discuss once you you have the data
let's say the data is uh faster files or
fastq files how do you process it to
generate a gene expression table what
other tools involved how to perform
exploratory data analysis how to perform
Downstream data analysis which would
include differential gene expression
analysis pathway analysis functional
enrichment analysis and in the
intermediate level we'll discuss about
pathway annotation we'll discuss about
visualization and validation of the
results and we'll also discuss about
regression and Factor regression
analysis and introduce you to machine
learning for machine learning we'll
discuss about unsupervised and
supervised uh analysis now both of these
levels beginner and intermediate levels
these both levels um have the Practical
Hands-On with regards to the tbio info
platform and also open resources where
when I say open resources I'm referring
to the databases and the tools or the
softwares that are uh present openly
that you can download or maybe uh
explore if it's a server so we'll
discuss how different tools online could
be used for rnsc canalysis as well along
with the pipelines on the server and in
the advanced level we will work with
computation languages R and python to
analyze RN data so the process would
start from from the very Basics on the
beginner level how to import data how to
perform exploratory analysis statistical
analysis cor correlation and regression
differential gene expression analysis
path analysis and unsupervised
supervised machine learning and uh we
had a participant who was interested to
learn about B and single cell analysis
that's why I wanted to explain the
advanced level here where you have
sessions on single cell RN analysis we
here discussed about uh the Single Cell
analysis workflow what tools to use what
parameters to use what the uh results
would be and how do you interpret them
once you have the results from the
pipeline you have to perform further
Downstream analysis for sell
identification through cell clustering
and that is done through R so how do you
do that and you'll learn everything step
by step in the RN analysis and those who
extend their program to the advanced
level towards the end of the advanced
level you'll get to work on a Capstone
project as well where we'll discuss your
research proposal and take it further uh
as a research project so that was about
the transcriptomic data an analysis
program and uh as a part of the program
you have the access to several cour
works that you can uh go through
transcriptomics using the server
transcriptomics in R and transcriptomics
in Python I'll explain you the
specificities of R and python coursework
through the Python program so that you
know what uh is
included because of the time limitation
it's uh not possible for me to go
through each one of the courses and
showcase you the topics that we are
covering please feel free to create an
account and you can explore the Amic
learn portal and see what all topics are
there now for the genomic data analysis
program we have the three different
levels specified here uh please take a
while to go through the curriculum while
picking up the course that you would
like to pick from and then comes the
biomedical data science using Python
program now for the Python program uh
there's definitely code block that we
need to practice right so for that we
have put together several Google collabs
uh and on the uh program page itself you
will find the link to the Google collab
so this is uh the Google collab that you
have to refer to uh for what is also uh
explained in the session videos and you
have to create a copy of this Google
collab and then practice with the collab
practice your code blocks and if you get
any errors you need to reach out to us
and uh we prefer that you work with the
Google collaps because it's easy for us
to check your errors help you with your
errors and easy to process with so that
was about the Python
program now let's quickly uh go through
the tbio info platform for those who
have joined us for the first time so
this is the tbio info
platform meanwhile it log in I also show
you the metagenomics program it got
skipped so the metagenomics program
similarly has these three levels and you
can uh go through the curriculum here
and then you have the coursework and the
case studies case studies is one of the
things that I would like to discuss
let's go over the pipelines first and
then let's see what case studies are
that you can learn from so this is the
tbio info platform where you have these
different areas of analysis
transcriptomic data analysis genomic
data analysis cancer bio single cell
metagenomics phology and here's a
section for machine learning uh Jas and
F genetic analysis and differential
expression as well now when I mentioned
demo pipelines The Links of the demo
pipelines that were present on the
program page those are basically these
demo pipelines these are basically uh
the Pipelines for specific case studies
on the uh portal now when I say case
studies under the courses tab itself if
I type transcript
Tomas along with the coursework I'll get
uh several case studies as well these
are case studies now these case studies
are for you to understand how to apply
the concept that you learn in the
coursework to real life research
questions and uh the coursework is quite
lengthy because we are discussing about
each and every step from the very uh
Basics to the adanced analysis that
would be required and uh just one thing
a lot of uh participants get confused
with the lessons there's a button called
load more here that will load all the
lessons so don't miss out on the lessons
now the case studies are not very
lengthy uh they are short case studies
within application of the concept so you
you should go through uh one of the case
studies at least to understand the
application okay now for each case study
you have a case study uh pipeline here
that you'll get under the uh drop- down
button I'll open one of these uh case
studies pipeline to Showcase you what it
includes now it's named demo just
because the data is already uploaded at
the back end it's a pre-processed
pipeline you need to um process it just
to look at the algorithms that that are
being used and understand how to
interpret the results so this is a
differential gene expression analysis
pipeline which takes the data and uh you
upload the file the raw count file with
two groups and then you use these
different algorithms for differential
expression analysis and uh path
enrichment analysis function enrichment
analysis is and you get your results the
motive behind process processing a
pipeline is definitely one is it's quick
it's uh efficient it will give you your
results in a short span of time and it
gives you all the results all the
possible results it's very important for
you as a learner to understand what
these results are and how to interpret
them so we have two different types of
results one is the interactive
visualization that you can open and
change the parameters play with the
parameters and then learn from them and
then you have these files that you can
directly download these These are zipped
folders uh you can download them unzip
them and then look at the uh
results um because it's a orientation
session my motive is not to explain each
and every result but just to Showcase
you how easy it could be uh to process
these pipelines get your results and uh
also interpret them effectively and you
have these interactive results that you
can uh explore and uh extract meaningful
insights because this was a demo
pipeline I got the results uh the moment
I clicked on the end button but if you
run the pipelines for your own analysis
it would just take few minutes to few
hours to process the data and give you
your results based on again the sample
size and the uh file size so this is a
heat map where you can look at the
differential gene expression of
different samples these are some of the
top differentially expressed genes and
uh then you have a volcano plot again
you can interact with the volcano plots
look at the position of the genes what
is the fold change and then you have a
dashboard in the dashboard you can
change the par parameters and see how
your results change uh so if you are
working on a research project
experimenting with the parameters would
be one of the useful things that you
could do from a dashboard you have a
heat map here as well there's something
wrong with the name of the sample that
should be short though but uh yeah it's
a clear heat map here in this case it's
uh short but you can change the lock
fold change and see how the heat map
changes at top jeans line graph and you
also have the
pathway uh analysis result here which
pathways are affected uh how many genes
are there and then you also have the
code block uh for you have the data here
you have the emble IDS the annotations
are there the gene symbols and The
annotation is here the statistical the
calculated statistical values are there
then you also have the code block that
you you can download and maybe practice
uh yourself once I downloaded the
results here I'll just show this to you
so one we have the plots that you can
download this is a volcano plot with the
mentioned Gene names for Publications
obviously you have to refer to this
volcano blot the interactive one is for
you to uh extract insights uh while
changing the parameters you can unzip
the file here and then look at the
results that you get you'll get uh
detailed Excel sheets and that you can
export this is just a differentially
expressed file where you have the
calculated statistical values and then
there's a lot more to explore uh so as a
part of the program you'll get the
credentials to the T bio info platform
take some time out you can uh click on
the drop down button you have several
demo pipelines here that you can learn
from see what type of results you get
and how to interpret them the
interpretation is mentioned in the
coursework so it would be helpful to you
so that was all that I wanted to discuss
today and if there are any questions
please feel free to unmute yourself and
uh
ask I hope uh I didn't not uh bow you
all but it was quite an interesting
session I see Robert has joined us hi
Robert I did not uh hear from you could
you please introduce yourself what is
your backgr around are you a researcher
or a student you are in which
lab hi there uh yeah my name is Robert
I'm a a graduate student at
UNLV looking into and I wanted to take
this course because we're getting
into uh RNA
seek and kind of like more
transcriptomic stuff so I wanted to take
this course to kind of brush myself up
on those skills
all right okay so uh I hope you uh did
go through the program page of
transcriptomics when I was explaining
were you there or you joined after that
no yeah I saw that you saw that all
right perfect so uh feel free to go on
the program page and one more thing I
think we did not uh add the transomics
program uh in the flyer of the Navy
offered programs so just wanted to let
you know that this program is also up
there because we got a lot of uh
requests for this program so we had it
up for the fall as well so take a while
go through the curriculum and then we
can get started next week are there any
questions yes Dr chat has put his
queries in the chat okay in order to
access the beginner or Advanced modules
for transcri toomics of basic
bioinformatics will be be pay uh so okay
Dr chatter G are you here yes okay so I
don't uh think that's the amount that
you need to pay there's a specific
scholarship on that uh o can you please
take up this question I'm so sorry I'm
very bad with numbers I was just trying
to explain the conceptual Things o Jesse
can you take this question
please
yeah hi uh can you just read this
question I was just typing something so
so uh Dr chat is asking um will they do
they need to pay the total do 600 for
each of those if she wants to get the
access to the big or the advanced
modules of the
program uh like two different programs
or one program because because I see Dr
chat have already enrolled in synomics
but if you want if she wants to change
to let's say transcript Comics or python
or if she's interested in both so we can
give her like 10 person scholarship and
enroll in advance I will like send the
pending
invoice because some amount is already
paid so for NP uh participants there is
a discount
okay so
uh is the best person to contact for the
programs
enrollment yep was saying something
sorry yeah and I guess Robert has also
enroll in introduction to bi informatics
but if he's interested in transcrip
comics so he can change his enrollment
or maybe he can enroll in both and I'll
see the invoicing accordingly like I
have their emails and I guess we are
already in touch through
np. uh this email ID I'm just sharing in
the
chat
yes for any enrollment related uh issues
you can reach out to OES he has shared
his uh email ID in the chat and this is
for the ones who are from nipi and the
ones from lbrn o just uh where do
the same email ID yeah they can email me
on uh np1 yeah okay this is my another
email so anyone can reach out
anywhere all right thank you and uh for
resources let's say uh so every week
you'll get the resources on your email
as well all right the resources would be
updated timely on the program page also
but you'll also get it on the Emil email
in case you don't get it please check
your spam folder make sure we are in
your inbox and not spam and uh if that
there is any uh resource that you need
or you missed on something or if you
have any question please reach out to us
on communication atate omx logic or
sorry find. bio communication atate
find. bio you uh Shri gari looks after
this email and uh if if you have any
conceptual question you can reach out to
me directly atalik find. bio and we
are planning to have live Q&A sessions
there was a a Time issue last time so we
were meeting some of the participants at
9:00 a.m. Cs and some of them uh at 1:30
or even in the evening at 7 p.m CSD so
because you have enrolled in the program
we need to stay in touch for your
questions for doubts please let us know
uh what time works for you yes we can do
a doodle poll uh just we suggesting you
can do doodle poll to understand what
time works for you and uh if we have two
different CS uh for morning or evening
we can have two different meets that's
not a problem for
us yes uh we will share the recording
with you Dr
n
yes all right thank you everyone for
joining if there are no questions I
think we are good to end the call and Dr
Maria your qu query for python uh
actually we were having up
the Practical sessions for each
algorithm each supervised ml algorithm
that's why the session got delayed but
by the end of today you should uh
receive all these different sessions it
is little heavy where we are discussing
about each algorithm so we wanted this
session to be very much detailed like in
depth that's why it got delayed so we'll
share it with you today and you can go
through it okay thank
you about your analysis we'll also get
back to you we are working on
it yes thank you everyone for joining
and uh we'll see you next week uh we'll
have the sessions shared by next week
and let's get started thank you bye-bye
thank you
everyone thank you Shari
by